[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 tout de suite les
titres de ce mercredi 24 octobre
c'est en ce moment la semaine de la
parentalité aux clayes-sous-bois un
événement consacré à l'aide et au
soutien et des papas et mamans un
atelier massage pour bébé était par
exemple proposé hier à l'espace social
de sémaphore une technique plein de
bienfaits pour le nouveau-né mais aussi
pour ses parents mercredi jour de sortie
au cinéma pour notre petit tour
hebdomadaire dans les salles
saint-quentinoise ne nous rendrons ce
soir au ciné c'est t il encourt en ces
vacances de la toussaint et quels sont
les films à l'affiché
la réponse à suivre enfin l' approche
d'halloween intégrer une école de
sorciers comme harry potter c'est le
défi lancé par la bergerie nationale à
rambouillet pour y parvenir les enfants
doivent résoudre une série d'énigmes
reportage de la fin de cette édition
et puis invités de ce journal ali
bousselham candidat à 100 esi sans
étiquette pardon à l'élection municipale
partielle à coignières le premier tour
et au programme le 25 novembre à
l'occasion de la semaine de la
parentalité aux clayes-sous-bois des
ateliers initiation au massage bébé sont
notamment organisés au sémaphore le
service de la petite enfance de la ville
propose d'en découvrir tous les
bienfaits on ne connaît pas tous mais
ils sont nombreux les détails de manon
varaldo des bébés plus détendu grâce à
des massages bien-être
durant une heure et quart auxiliaire de
puériculture et éducatrice pour jeunes
enfants ont expliqué les bons gestes aux
parents pour les apaiser
chaque massage a sa petite histoire un
papillon qui se posent sur la jambe et
qui s'envole pour arriver à ses pieds
des histoires qui participent à la
détente du bébé et qui permettent aux
parents de mieux retenir les gestes dans
la façon
le pape y faire des massages du pied à
votre enfant à l'aide de votre pouce
exercé de légères pressions sur les bras
et des petites frictions sur les jambes
ou encore massage de la tête tant de
techniques donné que reproduisent les
mamans pendant ce moment de douceur des
hormones de plaisir sont sécrétées ce
qui procure une sensation de détente au
bébé et stimule le développement
sensoriel
mais avant chaque massage les mamans
sont invités à appliquer de l'huile sur
leurs mains pour la faire chauffer et à
tout un protocole pour masser un enfant
ont fait par partie en général c'est à
dire on commence par les gens les bras
pour bien là c'est un enfant faut rester
dans un endroit agréable avec une
température assez élevée de 23 degrés et
il faut effectuer des pressions assez
douces
un peu comme quand on va se faire masser
et lors du massage une relation
privilégiée secret entre l'enfant et le
parent deux autres initiations seront
proposées demain à l'espace jacqueline
auriol c'est gratuit sur réservation
politique comité départemental hier pour
les républicains des yvelines à poissy
le premier depuis l'élection de pierre
bédier à la tête de la fédération est le
nouveau président de l air 78 qui
apprenaient l'ouverture il a accordé
deux vice-présidences ses anciens
adversaires pendant la campagne
alexandra du blanche devient vice
président en charge du projet othman nas
roux sera chargé des élections a noté
que la mère d'orson ville anne cabri est
nommé secrétaire départemental
valérie pécresse gérard larcher ou
encore alain schmitz intègrent eux
le bureau de la fédération yvelinoise on
continuera de parler politique tout à
l'heure avec ali bousselham candidat
sans étiquette à la municipale partielle
à coignières et qui doit encore nous
rejoindre dans cette émission
informations pratiques à présent les
médiathèques du réseau de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines fermeront
exceptionnellement à partir du 5
novembre tout comme les boîtes de retour
et le site web les sept médiathèques
change de logiciel et le portail i
médiathèque est mise à jour par
conséquent
près de vos documents sera
automatiquement prolongé il faut
cependant sauvegarder vos paniers de
sélection sur le site internet
réouverture prévue le 13 novembre et nos
visites du mercredi à présent dans les
cinémas de saint quentin en yvelines ce
soir direction et l'encours et le ciné 7
son directeur luc beau quand elle nous
présente le programme est des vacances
dans le cinéma est les propos sont
recueillis par patrick jacques de
dixmude cette semaine au ciné cette un
certain nombre de films
vacances obligent détente oblige plutôt
des comédies dont le dernier enfin le
premier véritable avant première
véritable réalisation de gilles
lellouche pardon le grand bain film très
attendu que je n'ai pas encore vu dont
je peux pas vous en parler mais le film
est très très attendu voilà il est
accompagné du film de michel blanc voyez
comme on danse de star is born de
bradley cooper qui marche très très bien
à la deux pour les jeunes et pour les
plus petits vous pourrez voir y étiez
compagnie chair de poule 2 le très beau
film de michel ocelot d'il y à paris et
pour les ados plutôt la prophétie de
l'horloge voilà pour le programme du
ciné set cette semaine vacances de la
toussaint oblige
[Musique]
et notre invité nous a rejoint sur ce
plateau ali abou selha bonsoir vous êtes
candidat sans étiquette à la municipale
partielle à coignières elle se déroulera
le 25 novembre pour le premier tour un
éventuel deuxième tour sera au programme
le 2 décembre alors une municipale qui a
été rendue nécessaire après la démission
de jean-pierre sevestre et de plusieurs
élus
vous êtes à limoux c'est même le 2è
maire-adjoint de coignières vous faites
partie de ces élus de la majorité qui
s'était opposé à jean pierre sevestre
notamment au moment du projet de fusion
avec maurepas qui est ensuite abandonné
vous étiez entrer en conflit ouvert avec
le maire qui vous avez retiré vos
délégations
j'invite les téléspectateurs à retrouver
l'ensemble des reportages sur ce sujet
sur notre site internet
première question pourquoi être candidat
pour cette élection
bonne question effectivement donc en
réalité les événements que vous venez de
citer ont remis la population dehors
vous avez pu le constater je compte vous
avez vu sur le terrain également avec
d'autres journalistes et il ya eu deux
phases la première phase ils sont sortis
pour faire manifester leur
désapprobation vis-à-vis du projet de
fusion d'une part et d'autre part suite
à cela le conflit effectivement vous
avez raison et est ouvert entre monsieur
enfin monsieur seul est le maire
démissionnaire et moi même nous avions
d'autres désaccords auparavant mais par
pudeur et par respect mutuel des uns et
les autres nous avons nous les avons
laissés on va dire en privé
bon voilà c'est un groupe de gens qui
vit avec des opinions et des
sensibilités mais ça s'était accumulé
une certaine manière est là ça a été
on va dire le vraiment l'élément
déclenchant c'était quelque chose qui
était tout à fait qui vend pour nous il
n'y avait pas moyen de trouver un
arrangement sur la sur cette question là
vous aviez reçu le soutien de plusieurs
habitants de quoi il ya cette année
plusieurs alors la deuxième étape c'est
lorsque monsieur
le maire démissionnaire avait dans la
presse fait publier des propos qui
étaient erronés me concernant était faut
simplement concerne le mot logement vous
en doutez donc je vais apporter la
preuve écrite prise sur la toile pour
prouver ma bonne foi et j'ai été très
surpris parce que c'était pas élégant et
pas très pas très loyal je m'étais je ne
serais jamais permis
personnellement en tout cas jamais
d'attaqué par une personne de quelques
natures ce soir c'était clair nous
étions totalement en opposition par
rapport à ce projet là et ce projet-là
été induits en amant une politique qui
était déjà de toute façon désapprouvée
par une bonne partie du bureau et
quelques-uns de nos conseillers de la
majorité
cette candidature c'est pourquoi c'est
par confiance alors c'est je vais vous
dire des mots un peu désuet mais tant
pis je les assume c'est ma nature
moi je me sens une dette morale et une
dette d'honneur à l'égard de la
population
elle s'est levée romas justement pour
défendre mon honneur pour expliquer
aujourd'hui c'est de faire ramener le
calme a conscience de l'huma parler nous
a scellé des sujets absolument rien pour
nous enfin en tout cas pour moi en
l'occurrence et surtout pour les
colistiers nous avons tourné cette page
là c'est plus un sujet là la fusion
c'est comme ça c'est tant mieux pour les
connais rien en tout cas et à partir de
ce moment là nous sommes nous allons
nous concentrer vraiment sur les besoins
et les touts ses pieds
tout ce qui est attendu par la
population indiqué par exemple à nos
confrères de la gazette de 50 en une que
votre programme allait ressembler aux
promesses de fait en 2014
vous étiez à l'époque élu sur la liste
d'henri pailleuse qui a démissionné
après en 2015 qui faire quels sont ses
promesses justement quelles sont leurs
priorités rance à un des gros projets
qui a malheureusement capoté pour
d'autres raisons en amont c'était le
projet de rénovation de la du gymnase
c'est une promesse qui est de longue
date mais à chaque fois on a vu des des
soucis avec les appels d'offres
plusieurs appels d'offres ont été
déclarés infructueux et là vous savez
que les procédures sont relativement
longue donc il faut remonter encore des
d'autres projets qui soient viables bien
évidemment et là normalement on devrait
on devrait pouvoir aboutir ce
c'est un projet qui est pratiquement
mais table en oeuvre d'une manière assez
rapide
derrière ça nous avions si le projet de
délocaliser les actions jeunesse qui est
actuellement dans le gymnase pour la
mettre sur un autre endroit avec un avec
un ensemble architectural modulaire
assemat c'est assez attractif plutôt
moderne avec des pôles d'un format tiff
à des choses un peu plus vivant tpiy
sortant de sa vocation exclusive de la
jeunesse pour essayer de faire de
l'intergénérationnel et permettent en
fait à d'autres populations de notre vin
d'autres types de populations de n'être
connu de pouvoir s'y rencontrer que ce
soit des scolaires que ce soit les
personnes âgées que ce soit peu importe
mais se créer un lieu de rencontre et
d'échangé à partager ça aussi c'est très
proche c'est très près et puis on a
aussi à reconstruire important de rien
avec notre notre notre voisin la ville
de maurepas comme vous le savez là le
projet de la piscine intercommunale
n'est plus à l'ordre du jour mais ça
veut pas dire que nous sommes là pour
rompre avec tout le monde
nous nous souhaitons nous souhaitons
pouvoir le faire dans des conditions
mutuellement profitable évidemment il
conclu pour les deux populations dans un
esprit serein apaisé avec avec de la
bonne volonté en 20 secondes où on
arrive déjà la fin de cet entretien de
duty sera constitué votre liste et ce
qui aura d'autres élus il y anciennement
de la majorité il y aura d'autres élus
alors ne le prenez pas mal je vais
essayer de garder la primeur de cette
information pour pour nous notre
population
ce que j'ai pas eu l'occasion - de
tracts et pour des raisons très simples
vous savez que je ne suis pas un
politicien professionnel tout le monde
le sait et je ne m'en cache pas pour les
parents moi je suis là pour servir
aujourd'hui le moment est venu pour moi
d'aller jusqu'au bout de cette cette
envie de servir la population
du coup dans les dents les prochains
jours merci à lee oui c'est la ville
d'avoir été avec nous merci de m'avoir
accueilli et puis écouter à suivre les
candidats sans étiquette donc à cette
municipale partielle à coignières qui se
déroulera au pour le premier tour en
tout cas le 25 novembre
allez un peu de magie à pour refermer ce
journal après les cowboys et les indiens
est la bergerie nationale de rambouillet
lance un défi aux enfants faire ses
preuves pour intégrer l école des
sorciers agri enchanteur marylène yapi
chinois suivi les honore et maël qui ont
tenté leur chance regarder pendant les
vacances les honorer ma elles sont venus
récupérer leurs grilles mois à la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet il
roule qu'à 16h30 pour résoudre les
énigmes
on a pris un thème qui s'appelle sait
pas que sorciers avec l'idée de faire un
mix entre des choses qui peuvent sembler
un peu magique et des choses qu'on va
expliquer de façon un peu scientifique
gratter le ballon avec de la laine pour
avoir en tout mais s'il ya quelque chose
mais là ya quelques minutes le frère et
la soeur maîtrise le sort de lévitation
ils parviennent à déchiffrer le code qui
se cacher sous les feuilles d'aluminium
[Musique]
après au mont-dore direction sabots tard
pour retrouver les caractéristiques d
équité magique
les apprentis sorciers ont réussi à
maîtriser le cheval noir il faut
désormais regarder le plan pour se
rendre dans les classes de verre de lait
après les sortilèges et la théorie des
animaux fantastiques place aux potions
un bon sorcier doit savoir reconnaître
une composante bar match j'ai pas trop
mal une fois la liste des ingrédients
trouvés ils apprennent à maîtriser plume
et encre invisible chesser de coque
avant de se rendre à la dernière épreuve
des chiffres est le secret de large et 1
re reste à se frayer un chemin 500
participants ont tenté leur chance ce
jour là c'est une très bonne activité
ludique qui se sont bien amusés sont
bien pris au jeu et puis bon ben là
c'est des sorciers ils vont aller voir
les ils vont prendre le temps d'aller
voir les animaux léonore et maël n'ont
plus qu'à se procurer robe de sorcier et
baguette magique pour faire leur
nouvelle rentrée dans le monde des
sorciers
c'est la fin du journal belle soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]